government is saying today that you know
everything would have been easy with
hindsight and a lot of the criticism is
hindsight do you think that is a
an acceptable explanation
well it's never easy to be in these
roles but i mean we have done as the
report laid out pretty badly in the uk
and
specifically in the first way we were
late on testing we were late on border
measures we were late on actually um you
know locking down once it was widely
seated that led to a longer lockdown
because longer it takes to go up longer
takes go down on your epicurve and so i
think there has to be some
acknowledgement that mistakes were made
and you have to hold up your hand up and
say they were made and how do we make
sure that we give some justice to the
families who were affected businesses
who were affected through a very
prolonged lockdown the kids who were out
of school because we had to shut down
everything to bring things under nhs
capacity um and then you know move
forward to say we're gonna do better
next time
is there a sense in which some
scientists or medical public health
officials rather epidemiologists
were happy to go along
with or too happy to go along with
political decisions
it's a really tricky one because what
you're taught like in scientific advice
is you offer options and then you step
back and you let politicians decide what
they want to do and they're really
difficult decisions to be honest i mean
imagine saying we're going to shut down
heathrow at the end of february when you
know there weren't really widespread
transmission yet but that's when you
would have had to shut down a lot of the
air traffic to stop the seeding of the
virus some places did that molly shut
down before its first cases it's a
different thing if you're mali or
britain
but i think you know the real lesson
here is that science has delivered
solutions for our major infectious
disease challenges for hiv we didn't get
a vaccine we have antiretrovirals for
malaria we now have a vaccine and
anti-malarials with this there were so
many vaccine trials there were hundreds
that started so many therapeutics being
trialled that the countries that said
let's wait let's wait if science can
find a solution those populations look
at east asia and australia new zealand
they can now vaccinate they can acquire
this merck antiviral pill they're going
to protect their populations and open up
without the loss of life we experienced
yeah i mean and this
you know they're talking about group
think
that i suppose arguably could include
you you were you were advising the
scottish government what did you what do
you think of this the use of this phrase
group think
well i think if we look at the timeline
so sage was not transparent at that
point who was on it in the minute so i
didn't even know who was on it in march
i always got involved in the media in
mid-march when the uk
didn't go into lockdown on march 12th
and i was like okay something's off
because i had been studying as an
international expert what was happening
in east asia and so i only got involved
at the early april my first meeting was
april 2nd on the scottish advisory group
meeting and actually i give respect to
the scottish government for taking one
of the harshest critics of the early
response in march as i was outspoken and
saying okay if you think you know what
you're doing then come help us and tell
us what we should be doing and at that
point we tried to get testing up and
going we tried to get isolation policies
we tried to hold lockdown longer in the
summer to get the numbers lower we tried
to ring and border policies we tried to
get those things in place but obviously
it couldn't undo what had happened in
march and april okay professor sridhar
thanks very much for your time thank you